oh so many options if I'm not really
from find someone that know some view
shown it's not a positive work in
Chinese it just feel that someone be
abandoned some girl he abandoned that is
not a good feeling of being
that will power my whole toy war
I usually go to service entire Coachella
I don't need all that that's it yeah how
does this work
wait this is a corporation charges since
you're hopeful click or click on my my
formation mug we all cast with hat
mmm wait your money all Carson hat do I
sell wish I move off hey Cleve showing
you on your knees out so you want me all
cost
oh yeah ok yeah well she'll get her
Tommy Lee
so hello physics you've broken it up ha
ha ha ha ha ha ha sirisha
it's sweaty
I cannot change my parents especially
their salt there's nothing that I could
do so I think maybe just to work hard
and be a bad person and let them feel
you know proud of me it's a nother way
to tell my mom oh I'm really good in my
life
you